je vous le disais dans les titres à un
incendie s'est déclaré cette nuit dans
la tour et toiles de 18 étages qui se
situe sur les bords de loire entre tours
et la riche un feu d'appartement qui
s'est soldée par la découverte d'une
personne décédée une enquête est en
cours pour déterminer s'il s'agit d'un
accident ou d'un suicide
le point avec samuel colin 21h45 hier
soir une explosion et un départ
d'incendié dans cette tour de 18 étages
le feu part de cet appartement situé au
12e niveaux
plusieurs riverains donne l'alertent les
secours sont sur place en moins d'une
dizaine de minutes les habitants
descendent lui logement commence déjà à
évacuer par les escaliers
c'est ma belle-fille caisse au sixième
étage avec mon fils qui m'a appelé à ma
pelle jamais à cette heure-là donc que
j'ai tout de suite senti qu'il y avait
un danger et mathilde laissant tout de
suite donc en pyjama voilà on savait pas
ce qui s'était passé on l'a su qu'un peu
plus tard à l'intérieur de l'appartement
les pompiers retrouvent le corps d'une
femme proche de la cinquantaine
l'explosion serait due à sa bouteille
d'oxygène et à une cigarette qu'elle
allume pendant les opérations de secours
une solidarité se met en place à
l'extérieur pour les plus fragiles
certains riverains les accueillent leur
offre du café pratiquement tout le
bâtiment est descendu sauf ceux qui
malheureusement n'ont pas entendu ou
dormait tellement profondément que n'ont
pas entendu répond qu'est et elle
quelques frayeurs chez certaines
personnes mais c'est normal c'est
toujours stressant
deux personnes sont évacuées à l'hôpital
à cause d'un malaise à minuit tous les
autres habitants peuvent rejoindre leurs
logements dans la tourbe allant le
parquet de tours ouvre ce matin une
enquête en recherche des causes de la
mort une autopsie de la défunte doit
être réalisée